hello belief nation today we're going to
talk about the seven steps that you can
take now to get wealthy in 2017 all
right so it's the end of the year it's a
great time to reflect on the year that's
been C if you hit your goals or not see
if you are where you want to be or not
and start planning for 2017 to make it
the best year you've ever had so today
I'm going to share the seven steps you
could take right now to get wealthy in
2017 step number one is have a goal and
that's going to be probably the most
common bit of advice you get when you're
trying to figure out what your plan
should be for 2017 and planning for the
year ahead and I think it's important
that you don't just set another goal
that doesn't happen you don't just set a
wish right you said something that I
think that I can get this done you set a
goal that is motivating that you look at
and say I would love to have that happen
and that feels like not just realistic
don't just play small don't you say like
hey you know I did
25k this year I want to do 30k next year
think about I'm gonna work really hard
to grow and achieve this thing and it's
something that truly comes from you not
because you listen to me not because you
put on a Tony Robbins tape I remember
listening to Tony Robbins and I love
Tony and and he was talking write down
your goals and it was like if you want
to make a sculpture write that down you
want to do a painting write that down
you want to have a manuscript write that
down again oh yeah I want to do that too
I love that you know I want to I want to
have a painting write because I was so
caught up in Tony's energy and
enthusiasm and it wasn't actually what I
wanted to do and so get excited by the
thing that's on that piece of paper that
I want to go out and make this happen
and the more specific it is the more
it's not just you know I want to be
happy about my life something specific
then the easier it is to go entertain so
set your goals
[Music]
number two is create a better
environment and this one is so so so so
important create a better environment
chances are the reasons why you didn't
accomplish your goals from last year was
because your environment sucks because
you have the goals that make you want to
go out here but your environment pulls
you right back down to where you are
right your friends your family your
habits your routine all of that stuff
keeps you where you are and so when you
think of that bold goal that you want to
go and reach for next year think about
what kind of environment you need to
have around you now who are the people
that you need to have around you what do
you need to have in your physical space
wherever you're working in your office
in your home what's on the wall what
music are you listening to what videos
are you watching what books are you're
reading you need to create an
environment that set you up for success
daily every single day I don't know
about you guys but for me I can be so
fired up I'm fired up today coming
across and then tomorrow like I'll be on
fire the rest of the day I'll be
creating amazing things for you guys
pumping up more believe in to the world
and tomorrow gonna wake up it'll be God
I wake up like okay what do I do right
and I have my schedule but what I do in
my routines every day gets me back up to
a high as soon as possible so I wake up
I go to the bathroom and then I start
putting on some music music to change my
state to get me pumping to get me moving
to get me feeling a little bit of action
then I'll go work out I'll be watching
videos we're gonna watch the videos to
feed my brain to not just not just give
me the knowledge but also give me the
the motivation the inspiration seeing
somebody hit it hard makes me want to
hit it harder hit it harder the workout
and then hit it harder when I finish and
start doing my work for the day and so
it's so so so so so so important that
when you set that big goal for yourself
that's inspiring and motivating you then
think about what's the environment that
I need around me to be able to hit that
goal and then how can you get started
immediately on it whether that's
changing your friends putting something
on the wall listen to music and Anna
just like try things right now
don't wait till 2017 try things right
now and see do I get that feeling
think about when you've been most
motivated in your life what happened
where you add a seminar were you
watching the video was there a song
playing like when do you get pumped up
and inspired and feel unstoppable what
happened just before you felt
unstoppable what was the stimulus and
then instead of randomly waiting for
that to happen inject that with
intention every day into your life so
whatever that is do it as one of the
first things you do every single day so
you get hit and like I'm going to go do
this today and I believe in myself I'm
gonna go attack that big goal because if
you have a big goal and you don't have
the environment to support you the goal
is never going to happen so create a
great environment
[Music]
number three is say yes to the
uncomfortable I want you to get used to
being uncomfortable when somebody asked
you to do things when you get an idea
that something you've never done before
when you see an opportunity in front of
you that might be scary say yes just get
used to doing something uncomfortable so
I've told the story before of how I wear
different colored socks I actually have
I had them on now I have two of them on
that let's see can I get the foot up
higher now can I get the foot up high
enough get it I can't get the foot up
high enough I'm going to take off my
shoes one two three no didn't happen I
gotta go further back one two three get
used to doing things that make you
uncomfortable yeah maybe there's people
behind me watching right but I wear
different colored socks a lot I took it
from my son he does it all the time and
the first time I tried doing it it was
because I thought of it because Hayden
does it and then the initial thought
that came up was well what do people
judge me for doing it when people think
I'm crazy for doing it then I had to do
it right as soon as you worry about
somebody else judging you get used to
going out and doing it feed off of that
discomfort because it builds the muscle
then it allows you to challenge more
conventional thinking it allows you to
push harder towards your goals and so
you know if it's something that might
cause physical harm with you know maybe
but a lot of the times the things that
you don't do because you're afraid of
doing it are the things that as you push
through them gives you the confidence
and strength and courage the go after
and push more and
more and push more so get used to doing
things that make you feel uncomfortable
and whenever you get an idea this is
important you start right now start
right now whenever you get an idea of
something that you feel like you would
love to try to do and you get that voice
inside your head that says oh you can't
do that because of whatever somebody
else's judgement as soon as you get that
feeling get used to stomping that out
and forcing yourself to go and do it and
you'll care less and less and less and
less about the opinions of others and
you'll listen to yourself more and more
and more and more and that is a habit
that will lead to a lot of wealth for
you a lot of success for you a lot of
impact for you in 2017 and beyond
[Music]
alright the number four step that you
can take right now to start getting
wealth in 2017 is build in some
accountability when you are accountable
to somebody else you much more likely to
follow through and so I would try to
find somebody that you can connect with
whether it's one friend whether it's a
mastermind group whether it's an online
group whether it's saying things
publicly to your Facebook friends or
YouTube channel or whatever it is
building accountability so that
something happens if you don't follow
through if you say you're going to do
this and then you don't as an
entrepreneur who cares right you're used
to letting yourself down you let
yourself down all the time and it's
really hard to hold yourself accountable
and the best entrepreneurs do that to
themselves they have so high standards
that they hold themselves accountable
all the time and are pushing to do more
but to build that muscle building some
accountability for yourself get some
people around you talk to your best
friend and say hey here's a goal that I
want to have can we meet once a week for
a quick phone call or for a coffee and I
happen to help push you whenever you
want to do if you want to lose weight
and go to the gym you're much more
likely to follow through when you have a
friend coming with you apply that to the
rest of your goals have a buddy an
entrepreneur buddy or or somebody else
one of your friends are trying to
accomplish something in their life great
connect weekly and push each other
because when you commit to somebody else
you're much more likely to follow
through and I want you to follow through
on your
I want you to stop letting yourself down
I want this year when you set that goal
that you actually go out and hit it and
a great way to do it is to build in some
accountability okay number five is talk
with customers at the end of the day if
you want to get wealthy it's going to
come from provide a lot of value it's
going to come from talking to customers
understanding what they need so whatever
you're creating you want to talk with
your end consumer and understand what
makes them tick what problems do they
have how can you help them if you want
to make a lot of money you need to
provide a lot of value you want to make
a lot of money quickly provide a lot of
value quickly and you get to understand
what kind of value is created when you
understand your customers better and the
problems they have so I would be setting
up as many meetings as I could with my
customers if you haven't started your
business yet with potential customers to
understand what's going through their
head what problems do they have how can
I help how can I make something that
will be super valuable for you stop just
thinking about things and planning
things and thinking that that's a great
idea and start talking to people who
will actually pay you they pay attention
to you and consume the thing that you
are going to make talk with them more
set up those meetings now so you can
have a wealthy 2017 step number six is
create create create you need to be
prolific in your creation you need to
create everyday you need to be creating
content product services whatever it is
for me it's videos right we're making
YouTube videos we're putting up Creve
YouTube videos at least every single day
I'm prolific in my creation if you look
at the people who are the greatest at
what they do they practice they work
they create and so yes you may need to
consume right at the start of my day I
can I'm a consumer at the start of every
single day right I'm watching videos I'm
listening to music I'm consuming that
stuff to get my mindset right so then I
can create right I made a video not that
long ago about how I don't want you to
watch every one of my videos right I
don't want you to watch every single
video I want you to watch the video that
applies most to you that
the title sounds interesting the
thumbnail brought you in and then use
the knowledge and apply it to your
business right take some action I want
you to take action I'd much rather have
you watch one video a month that speaks
to you and then you go out and do
something then just consume let's do
tubes goals they want you on YouTube as
long as possible right if you could
spend 24 hours a day on YouTube YouTube
will be so hack that's not my goal I
want you out making something and so
it's so easy to consume yes you need to
read books yes you need to watch videos
yes you need to listen to music yes you
need to have conversations yes you need
to go to seminars and conferences
whatever it is however you get off
however you consume information you need
to consume what you need to create more
and the most successful people are the
ones who start to tip that scale from
consuming so much and creating a little
bit too consuming a little bit and
creating a lot so I want you to start
now getting into the habit of creating
because through the process of creating
you'll discover what you're really good
at you'll discover what you could be the
best in the world that you'll discover
how to bring your artistic talent
through into creating something
massively valuable you'll discover how
to test a whole bunch of different
things and see which is the one that you
want to stick with instead of trying one
thing out you're trying a hundred
different things you have the time to be
able allocate do it you're testing that
what works with customers you're getting
feedback from them you're building
confidence in yourself I can yell at a
camera because I've done 4,000 videos
you watch my first ones and I sucked and
I was nervous and scared and you know
still the same content but my delivery
was not great and by doing it again and
again and again again by creating more
and more and more and more you get
better you can provide more value and
you can have more wealth in 2017 so yes
you need to consume but create create
create right now
[Music]
and number seven the number seven step
you could take right now to get wealthy
in 2017 number seven for me is to find
your one word it's back there I wrote a
book about it
I think self-awareness is one of the
biggest things that hold people back
finding your one word is about finding
the biggest core value that you have
understanding who you are as a human
being and then bringing that to your
life into your business so for example
if your one word is honesty then you
need to bring more honesty to your
business if you are a real estate agent
as an example a lot of people don't like
Melissa digits a lot of people think
real estate agents aren't very honest
great be the honest real estate agent
whatever that means right
what does honesty mean to you and bring
that to your business so you have
something that you saying for I would
love to work with the honest real estate
agent I think I have a pretty good one
but I would I would love to work with
the unsolicited or the honest programmer
or the honest graphic designer or
whatever it is you will attract
like-minded people to you who will love
working with you the guy who doesn't
care about honesty will be a terrible
client for you right because I don't
care about honesty just just give me the
work that's a terrible client he's going
to be the most difficult to come to work
with he's going to pay you the least
he's never going to refer you clients
he's going to give you grief all through
the process because your values don't
align and so when you figure out your
one word and then you bring that to your
business it allows people to find you
because now you're standing for
something that they can self identify
with where if I look at your website
it's probably super boring you're part
of looks like everybody else in your
industry there's no way to tell what you
do and how you're really that different
than everybody else because you're all
saying the same stuff so why am I going
to pick you maybe because I found your
business card or something like that but
why am I going to pick you give me a
reason to pick you give me a reason to
pick you don't be so boring inject more
of your personality your value into your
business where somebody looks at your
website says you are that you are the
honest programmer a lot of people look
at that and say that's the stupidest
thing I've ever seen amazing you will
never work well with those people let
them self eliminate where a lot of
people look that and say that's awesome
amazing I want to work with that person
and now you're not just another
programmer out of a hundred programmers
that are applying for this position or
being contacted or being searched for to
get that job to win that contract to get
that client you are clearly off in your
own world and people will self eliminate
if they don't fit and they'll push
towards you if they do and that's
exactly what you want so that's my take
that's what I think about the seven
steps you can take right now to get
wealthy in 2017 I'd love to know what do
you guys think what was your favorite
rule what do you agree with what don't
you agree with what do you want to add
what would your eight nine-ten be did I
miss something do you want to add
something to the list that I didn't
include leave it down in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love have
an amazing 2017 and I'll see you soon